When I visualize this new feature I get something that actually looks
quite good.
On the x axis I have the fraction of emails that this person gets that come from
persons of interest.
On the y axis is the fraction of emails that this person sends that they to
And I can see that while my red points aren't particularly tightly clustered.
There do seem to be big chunks of feature space where I don't see any persons of
interest at all.
So for example, if less than 20% of the messages that you send are sent to
persons of interest that puts you in this band of points down here.
And it means you're almost certainly not a person of interest yourself.
And patterns like this can be taken advantage of in your machine learning
algorithms to help give you better performance.